We are back now with one incredibly accomplished and special young woman.
Are you ready for this resume?
Okay, she is in two undergraduate programs studying biology,...
...I can't even say it,...
...biological sciences.
She's a former NASA intern, and now she's going to medical school.
And guess what?
She's 13 years old.
Oh man.
Alena Analeigh, so great to have you here in Times Square.
I'm glad I got a chance during the commercial break early...
...to go hang out with you in the green room,...
...and I don't know how you do it all.
What has been on your vision board?
What are your goals?
My goals right now are to definitely make it through college,...
...so I can go into med school...
...because after I was accepted, it was the most amazing moment.
And just knowing that I've reached the goal of getting into med school at this age,...
...at thirteen, was amazing for me...
...because my goal was to become a bioimmunologist, the study of viruses,...
...and really help communities.
I wanted to get involved.
I love to volunteer.
I've done that since I was young, like when I was…
You are young.
I mean like, once I was, when I was three, five, around there.
I always loved going out and volunteering, like feeding the homeless,...
...and doing projects with girls, and mentoring,...
...and it was a big part of my life.